en 2019 les libéraux justin trudeau ont
promis ceux ci on va baisser les
factures de ceulaer de 25% d'ici deux
ans aujourd'hui jazz meeting l'accusent
de ne pas avoir tenu son engagement la
prise ici prom ses promesses après deux
années de cette promesse encore les
frais sont très haut est ce que les
libéraux ont vraiment rompu leur
promesse de réduire de 25% la facture de
téléphonie cellulaire des canadiens
[Musique]
non ils sont plutôt sur la bonne voie de
la remplir
selon statistique canada le prix des
services de téléphonie cellulaire a
baissé en moyenne de 24% au pays depuis
la réélection des libéraux en octobre
2019 sous la menace d'imposer une
réglementation le gouvernement trudeau a
lancé un ultimatum ou 3 géants des
télécommunications bell rogers et telus
on leur a laissé deux ans pour réduire
le coût de certains forfaits cellulaires
selon une étude commandée par le
ministère de l'innovation ceux qui ont
des forfaits de deux giga octet de
données et - ont vu leur facture baisser
de 21 dollars de 2019 et 2020 une baisse
similaire a été observée pour les
forfaits de 5 gigaoctets bref plusieurs
indicateurs montrent que les libéraux
sont prêts d'atteindre leurs cibles par
contre les canadiens continuent d'être
parmi ceux qui payent le plus cher au
monde pour leurs services de téléphonie
cellulaire les prix des forfaits de 2 à
5 gigaoctets sont en moyenne deux fois
plus élevé qu'au royaume uni est quatre
fois plus élevé car le stand